very hyped up crowd tonight yes I know
why
well I know it's
because we're in Hollywood and the actor
strike is finally over
the for you uh you younger people
watching the the actors the people in
the movies pointing at the
CGI but uh no I worry I mean with the
actor strike over who's going to figure
out the Israeli Palestinian conflict on
Twitter oh here's where we
are here's where we are with that the
Museum of Tolerance here in La the
Museum of
Tolerance they had it showing a movie
about this and fist fights broke
out 14 people were treated for
irony
at the Museum of Tolerance that's where
we
are well and they were showing uh 43
minutes of the Hamas attack on October
7th in Israel and without any
editorialization just the footage that
they themselves Hamas took and wanted
the world to see but the prop
Palestinian people did demonstrate they
do not like this uh the college kids
especially think that the they prefer to
think of the Hamas people as just a kind
of a rag tag bunch of underdogs kind of
the Bad News Bears of the Middle
East this was uh a big Topic at the
Republican debate last night I don't
know if you saw that the uh oh I guess
not I didn't need I didn't I can't lie I
wouldn't
please well they're down to five
candidates on the island now and
uh all of them Trump is beating by 40
points the only reason to be in this is
to be there if Trump for some reason
can't run that's the one thing
Republicans and Democrats have in common
now they're both waiting for their
nominees to
die but there was a it was a good news
bad news week for the Democrats bad news
in in the six Battleground States Trump
is beating Biden in five out of six of
them and Biden support among non-white
voters dropped 33 points and this
Democrats cannot win with just white
people oh
oh although it hasn't hurt Taylor
Swift